[Music]
on this friday night getting behind
booster shots the new recommendation
canadian adults get a third dose of the
cobot 19 vaccine what we need to do now
is just to up our game regarding our own
immunity also a new weapon to fight the
virus and the lack of clarity on some
travel rules hiring spree the major
growth spurt in canada's employment rate
who's really fueling the fiery hot
housing market and the concerns about a
price correction plus getting their shot
they do a really good job of looking
strong and great and then can be
susceptible to really rapid decline the
mission to protect animals from covet
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
tonight with new developments in
canada's fight against covet 19. the
national advisory committee on
immunization is now strongly
recommending booster shots for canadians
over the age of 50. that message
reinforces policies already in place in
parts of the country canada's chief
public health officer says there is a
need for heightened vigilance
severe illness trends have leveled off
but are still elevated and could begin
to rise again unless we keep infection
rates down
the federal government is heeding its
own advice it has signed deals to
purchase more than a million potentially
life-saving covet-19 anti-viral pills
abigail beeman has our top story tonight
access to effective easy to use
treatments is critical announced by the
new procurement minister a new deal for
new copic drugs canada buying one
million of pfizer's antiviral pill and
up to half a million of mercs with
options for half a million more that's
pending health canada approval this is
absolutely to complement vaccines and
it's just another tool in the toolbox
but an important one we have to see the
actual raw data to be really certain
about how effective they are they
obviously do
something the question is going to
become is the benefit justified for
their cost because they are rather
expensive at the same news conference
the government also tried to clarify new
travel rules but won't say exactly when
all travelers except from the u.s will
have to take an arrival test at airports
and then isolate we are ramping up our
capacity quickly and testing more and
more travelers every day nor would the
health minister say how quickly
isolating canadians could expect to get
tests back canada's top doctor
eventually conceding it's quite
complicated i think we're going to have
to put up some tools on the website to
so that travelers can actually figure
this out the other cova news out of
ottawa friday an update from the
national advisory committee on
immunization now strongly recommending a
booster after six months for everyone
over 50 and other at-risk groups and
considered for those over 18. an
emphasis on those where the risk will be
greatest and the need is greatest and
then also creating opportunities
for others provinces have already been
rolling out their own booster plans next
week we will expand booster eligibility
to people in their fifties the way to go
is for many many people third dose
consider this to be a three dose vaccine
now getting his first shot friday one of
ottawa's most famous five to
eleven-year-olds the prime minister's
youngest son hadrian's very excited
about that sort of because i promised
him chocolate a negotiation many parents
know well abigail beeman global news
ottawa
vaccines are the best defense against
the virus and its variants growing
evidence shows covet-19 boosters can
significantly strengthen the body's
immune response and as eric sorenson
explains a new study shows it doesn't
really matter which shot you get so long
as you get them
immunity from vaccines diminishes over
time but if there was any doubt about
the value of a booster a new study not
only finds their effective but they work
well even when you mix brands a uk study
looked at those who received two doses
of astrazeneca or pfizer biontech they
received boosters for one of seven
vaccines including the four approved in
canada the effect was a boost of
antibodies and t cells against alpha
beta and delta variants equivalent to
over 90 percent protection against
infection and serious infection you get
a very good immune response that
involves the antibodies and in the t
cells which provide seem to provide a
more broad response against multiple
variants any of the approved vaccines at
the moment and the novel backs which
might get approval soon
also provide a very significant boost
the study also validates the decision
made by canadian health authorities that
mixed different vaccines based on
earlier trials after third doses up to a
few million canadians will have received
vaccines from different manufacturers
canada used data like that to help
inform its decision it was done with an
abundance of caution and done
thoughtfully but will current vaccines
and boosters help against the omicron
variant the study offers some hope there
too
it also is highlighting that in our
bodies we don't just make one antibody
we actually make a number of different
antibodies we are potentially
generating some antibodies that are
future proofed against omicron will have
to see meantime major manufacturers are
researching new vaccines to tackle
highly mutated variants bayern tech is
confident it can work up a response to
omicron within months
we have the ability to adapt the vaccine
it will take about
100 days yeah to develop a new and
distribute a new vaccine or start to
distribute the new vaccine even if a new
vaccine is distributed next spring it
leaves big questions hanging over the
winter will there be an omicron wave and
will our third doses defend against it
eric sorensen global news toronto
delta is still the dominant covid
variant circulating in canada and around
the world but experts in europe warned
that could change quickly if people
don't take the necessary precautions now
early new evidence out of south africa
suggests omicron is more transmissible
than delta and as crystal gamansing
explains a holiday party in norway is a
perfect example of just how quickly it
can spread
[Music]
oslo is on alert and reimposing covid19
restrictions masks working from home
when possible and public capacity limits
are all back
seated
norway's prime minister announced the
measures after news a christmas party
last week had been linked with a cluster
of new infections in the capitol one
person at the gathering of about 120
guests had recently been in south africa
and was infected with the omicron
variant the guests were all reportedly
vaccinated about half have now tested
positive for kovid and it's feared they
may have contracted omicron
if confirmed it would be the largest
single outbreak of the variant in europe
as you know when you see a surge of
infections it's two weeks later that you
start seeing that surge in
hospitalizations and deaths so i think
we need to wait
experts in south africa say the variant
appears to spread more than twice as
quickly as delta and reinfections are
occurring at three times the speed of
other variants but they need more time
to fully understand how omicron is
different
those currently falling ill in the
country are mostly young unvaccinated
people and pregnant women at this stage
we can say that even in houthi
which accounts for 72 to 80 percent of
the new daily infections
we have not yet reached threatening
stages
in terms of our hospital capacity the
new variant is leading to new demand for
vaccinations next week experts from
around the world will gather to set out
research priorities to better understand
omicron
crystal gomansing global news
london
in auckland new zealand after more than
100 days bars restaurants and gyms are
open beginning a new phase in its
pandemic response new zealand is using a
traffic light system to show where
outbreaks are happening a green
designation imposes few restrictions
auckland has started at red
there won't be lockdowns but people need
to be fully vaccinated to access many
services about 87 percent of people 12
and up have had two shots
a surprisingly strong job report could
have some major political and economic
implications statistics canada says
overall employment in this country is
now higher than pre-pandemic levels the
economy added 154 thousand new jobs in
november the national unemployment rate
dropped to six percent down from 6.7
percent in october and there was strong
growth in full-time jobs for women aged
25 to 54. that sector hit an all-time
high of 80.7 percent our chief political
correspondent david aiken joins us now
and david some good news on the job
front what's behind the games
the job report was good news colleen but
why what was it that sent thousands of
canadians into the job market in
november the answer pandemic fiscal
supports that ended in october with the
expiry of those fiscal supports uh
people
the job search intensity likely
increased and given that job vacancies
were pretty elevated they were able to
find jobs pretty quickly and that was
probably what was reflected in the
november jobs report crystal bunts found
part-time work in november when her
canada recovery benefits ended in
october but it was not work in her field
as a travel and entertainment
photographer november for her was hard i
think that
the government needs to be listening to
real people not just employers like the
people who are writing letters to the
government
are real people we need help
the trudeau government has tabled a bill
bill c-2 which it says would help by
extending financial support to workers
in hard-hit sectors like tourism and
hospitality or to people in regions
under lockdown across our nation we
still see that there's a number of
sectors a number of workers that still
need support and and certainly bill c2
is exactly doing that conservatives say
c2 is not needed the mp for an ontario
cottage country riding for example said
the biggest challenge for tourism
businesses in his region is finding
workers not finding customers
we've got countless local stories in
perry muskoka of small businesses
restaurants hotels
that are
open they're busy they've got lots of
business they can be open seven days a
week
but they can't find the staff to do it
the surprisingly strong job data is now
likely to force the bank of canada to
consider raising interest rates more
rapidly than it had anticipated we'll
get our first hint of how the bank feels
when it makes its regularly scheduled
interest rate announcement next
wednesday colleen
david aiken ian ottawa david thank you
turning now to bc where the sun made an
appearance for a second day in a row as
flood waters recede people in the
hardest hit areas are getting a sense of
what's been lost as they try to move
ahead in abbotsford and nearby sumas
prairie the lives of tens of thousands
of animals were lost in the flood but as
mike delay reports by helping one
another farmers were able to save most
of their livestock
there was a moment when the fraser
valley's dairy industry feared all would
be lost evacuating the 23 thousand cows
surrounded by rising flood waters was an
impossible feat
using trucks the army and anybody else
willing to help six thousand cows were
moved out i
basically don't know a farmer who hasn't
taken in some animals through this so
there's a smattering of cattle
everywhere right now the rest were
brought to high ground to wait out the
storm while only a fraction succumbed to
the elements when i heard the 500 number
i felt relief honestly as a farmer and
as we're going through it it sounds like
perhaps it's even lower than that the
waters may slowly be receding but the
crisis for more than 800 farms that are
still under an evacuation order remains
hardest hit appears to be the chicken
industry we're just shifting from
response to recovery
we're hoping that by early next week
we'll just be in full recovery mode
initial reports suggest 97 of the
chickens in the evacuation zone survived
which mark seaman attributes to their
quick response and more than a few
helping hands when moving out hundreds
of thousands of chickens proved to be a
logistical nightmare farmers enlisted
all the help they could get to keep
their barns dry and the birds warm
many fed their chickens by hand
hundreds of thousands still died there
were farmers down there late they lost
everything and ran over to the neighbors
farm to help him save it they've lost
everything their home their livelihood
it's gone they're starting from scratch
what's been communicated to me
by the farmers is that those numbers are
that they don't want to think about the
numbers they don't want to hear those
numbers they're very focused on moving
ahead but it won't be easy with roads
still washed out the supply chain could
take weeks or even months to recover
fourteen percent of our uh provincial
production comes from the sumas prairie
so
and some of that is already being picked
up again so that's heartening there's no
question the floods were and continued
to be a disaster but it could have been
far worse that the farming community
hadn't rallied together
mike relay global news abbotsford bc
the unrelenting eruption in spain coming
up the mighty la palma volcano flexes
its muscle again
[Music]
have a look at this jaw-dropping display
of mother nature's power the river of
lava spewing from spain's la palma
volcano is so strong it's pushing a
massive boulder downhill new jets of
red-hot lava are also blasting out of
the volcano the eruption has gone on for
more than two months and with new
fissures opening up there are no signs
it's relenting
in a rare move the parents of the
michigan teen accused of fatally
shooting four students at his high
school are facing four counts each of
involuntary manslaughter prosecutors say
james and jennifer crumbly purchased a
gun and gave it to their 15-year-old son
ethan ignoring the school's warnings
about his potential for violence state
authorities say the parents are now
missing u.s marshals and the fbi are
involved in the search ethan crumbly has
been charged as an adult with two dozen
crimes
the taliban is banning the forced
marriage of women in afghanistan its
chief issued the decree saying men and
women should be treated equal the move
addresses one of the demands set out by
the international community to recognize
the taliban as afghanistan's government
and to restore aid poverty is surging in
the country since the taliban takeover
in august since then thousands of girls
have been banned from attending school
and most women haven't been allowed to
return to work
canada's skyrocketing house prices ahead
which buyers are fueling the surge
it's been a tough couple of years for
the economy but there is one sector in
this country that remains hot real
estate home sales in vancouver are up
nearly 12
over last year the benchmark home price
hit 1.2 million dollars in toronto the
average home price is now above 1.1
million up almost 22 percent year over
year those sky-high prices are being
bolstered by domestic investors
canadians carrying two or more mortgages
and gaviola explains
gravity-defying home prices have become
a feature of the covet era reflecting a
rush of people getting into the market
with low mortgage rates many seeking
larger living quarters more green space
a change of scenery but there's another
big driver canadian investors not buying
a place to live but a vehicle for profit
real estate continues to be something
that attracts people ramona king helps
run a real estate search company she
says a lot of homeowners in vc's lower
mainland have taken advantage of higher
valuations in their primary residence to
buy another home and they purchased a
vacation property there that they also
know they can rent out so they can get
an income home purchases by domestic
investors soared during the pandemic
outpacing first-time home buyers and
repeat buyers according to the bank of
canada
terranet data shows that purchases by
people who own more than one property
climb two representing more than 25
percent of all transactions in the first
half of this year
analysis by equifax shows a bump in the
number of households carrying four
mortgages or more if you look at some of
the other provinces like uh alberta bc
there's a little bit of growth um but
you know not to the same degree that we
see in ontario and quebec and actually
manitoba has seen quite a lot as well in
a recent report the central bank says
the sudden influx of investors likely
drove up home prices and exposes the
market to a higher chance of a
correction
interest rates could be a concern next
year um you know on some like
non-mortgage debt but it really depends
you know i think consumers probably have
more buffer than we kind of have ever
seen before with interest rate hikes
looming next year and a big question
mark about how long the housing market
can stay this hot the prominence of
investor capital is making it harder for
first-time homebuyers to find a home ann
gaviola global news toronto
next the plan to protect canada's
susceptible species from cobot 19.
canadian zoos are eagerly awaiting a
package delivery but it has nothing to
do with the holidays a u.s
pharmaceutical company is donating 900
doses of a coveted vaccine made for
animals it's a product not on the market
yet but as mike armstrong explains it's
been approved for experimental use by
regulators on both sides of the border
there is a challenge in caring for
animals it's not just that they don't
tell you they're sick they actually hide
it it's instinctual in the wild they
can't look sick in case there are
predators around they do a really good
job of looking strong and great and then
can be susceptible to really rapid
decline well the toronto zoo is one of
six in canada about to get a new tool to
keep its animals from getting sick a
pharmaceutical company based in new
jersey has developed a vaccine
specifically for animals it started as a
product for pets cats and dogs but that
hasn't been necessary there have however
been cases in zoo animals the canadian
food inspection agency has approved it
for emergency use and the company says
it should ship in the coming days
south of the border the u.s department
of agriculture has also approved its use
and vaccinations are already underway
including at one of the biggest in the
country the smithsonian's national zoo
in washington d.c so far 76 animals have
received at least one dose the zoo's
chief veterinarian is very happy his
animals are now better protected in
september they did have an outbreak nine
lions and tigers were coughing and
sneezing tests confirmed it was coveted
19. we were hoping oh in a few days
they're going to be better because
that's what they do and that's not what
they all did three animals were severely
sick one we actually thought we talked
about euthanasia at one point due to
renal failure now there have been deaths
at some zoos from the coronavirus last
month the lincoln zoo in nebraska lost
three rare snow leopards
according to the association that
represents canadian zoos its members are
eager to get the vaccine but to this
point there have been no cases
we're very fortunate in canada thus far
knock on wood
but i know that that they're all
chomping at the bit
the washington zoo hopes to complete its
vaccination program by the end of
january for the most part it hasn't been
as hard as one might expect a lot of the
animals have been trained to accept
needles in return for treats some of
them get frozen juice treats
it might you know in the case of our
giant pandas they get honey water
now the washington zoo is also going to
be holding a vaccination session next
week for humans something that compared
to animals has so far been a bigger
challenge
mike armstrong global news washington
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's york canada is central park in
the city of spruce grove alberta all lit
up for the holidays we love seeing your
canada please email your holiday themed
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching robin gill will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night